it was one month one year and three
months ago in November 2014 right before
we started the workshop the first
workshop for lesson is the musical and
how did it come about why was it that he
decided to tell you oh it was to end up
Walsh in myself and he said well I have
to say you guys something because we
were going to work intensely together
and I want you to be to know why if I'm
not available or not there why this
that's what it is and you asked us to
keep it confidential which we both did
how did it affect him working during
that period well he worked a lot
actually any was there a lot you know so
it worked out really fine even wrote a
lot of new songs during this whole
period he broke not only wrote Blackstar
whole album but also four new songs for
the musical and it's all what he did in
this one year and a half so he was
really totally not giving in to his
disease into his cancer he was really a
fighter when did you last see him on the
night of the premiere in New York how
did you feel that he was at that point
did you think that this could be the
last time you saw him
yes he was fragile he came on stage with
us he looked of course very well you
know for the people in the audience but
he was Fred child and he we had a long
conversation backstage right after the
show but you know when it was beautiful
and he was still full of plans because
he said immediately let's make the
second one now
the second musical love sequel you know
we want to be the band that it was very
enthusiastic about the band that played
on this black star album and he said I
want to make immediately a new L so he
had not given him at all but he was
fragile so that work ethic that
determination was still there right
until the very end
yes it really was he didn't eat
don't want to die at all it was really
not a fight against death but the
struggle for life that's the way I felt
it and I must say I admire him a lot and
it was hard sometimes because you could
feel you know that he suffered from it
he really didn't wanna die he wanted to
go out and and when you listen now to
Blackstar when you listen to the new
song
Lazarus then yeah well everybody can see
that he was doing very very well yeah
wonder why you think that he wanted to
keep his illness and his impending death
so secret but that's what he did for
years now you know he kept everything
secret and the last line of black star
is the last line of the last song is
something I'm very bad at quoting but
something like I couldn't give it all
male that means like I gave everything
possible but I had to keep something to
myself and I must say as a human being I
totally respect that somebody keeps his
suffering and his death to himself to a
secret for him and his family I totally
can understand that and respect that
Tony Visconti produced the album
Blackstar described it yesterday as a
David Bowie's parting gift to his fans
what do you think the play Lazarus meant
to him and of course it's timing for me
it's like well it turns out that at
least to the play and musical ender
album are like two Testaments you know
they are full of singles everywhere you
know that you know that the famous song
Lazarus which is onion black star is the
title song of course of the musical and
he wrote it specially for the musical
that then he set in the summer well if
I've got to put it on my new album and I
thought well that's very meaningful you
know it's also that song it's haunted by
struggle for death and hoping for a life
after death how has his death affected
that the cast and crew of Lazarus
coincidentally yesterday they were also
recording
songs of the day that it was a good date
I said I really stayed together also
when it was all on tape they wanted to
talk together but me personally I lived
with the news for a little bit effects
already for a year and a half almost and
but the yesterday well I always have my
radio land two minutes before 8 o'clock
in the morning because I want to hear
news and the first news item in Holland
was David Bowie and even when I knew it
it was a total emotional shock and I was
overwhelmed immediately by a lots lots
of interviews and I didn't have time
even to think and to to think about it
and in the evening when I came home I I
must say it really it was very emotional
to me because I truly liked him I truly
loved him I can see it over and over
thank you very much indeed for talking
to us and our commiserations to you you
for having me thank you